sie alle wollen auf und davon die
bündner sabrina und markus blume tochter
amira suchen das einfache leben in der
kanadischen wildnis
vom zürcher oberland nach kambodscha
monika lehnert und peter kruse erfüllen
sich den traum vom eigenen kleinen
gasthaus
carolin schneider und daniel schaffer
aus dem kanton bern ziehen mit ihren
schlittenhunden nach schweden wo sie
eine campinganlage führen
[Musik]
vor einem monat kontrollierte peter
kruse noch billy es für die spd nun
füttert er krokodile in kambodscha
die tiere leben im brunnen von
guesthouse welches peter mit seiner
partnerin monika leonhard führen möchte
das gefährlich
hand verloren
die krokodile sind ein erbe des
vorherigen pächter smax
das problem mittels gewachsen sagen
sicherheitsrisiko riesig über
die krokodile müssen weg sind sich
monika und peter einig doch das ist nur
ein kleines problem verglichen mit der
belastungsprobe die den beiden
auswanderer noch bevorsteht
dabei hat in der letzten folge alles so
hoffnungsfroh begonnen
die haustiere die sie in der schweiz
zurücklassen mussten fanden ein gutes
plätzchen und die begrüßung in der neuen
heimat war herzlich
dann die ernüchterung vorgänger max von
dem sie das gästehaus übernehmen wollen
stellte sich quer
daniel schafe hütete zu hause die
schlittenhunde während seine freundin
carolin schneider in ab land eine
campinganlage suchte nach einer reihe
enttäuschungen fand sie am ende das
perfekte zuhause für mensch und tier
[Musik]
markus und sabrina bluhm verabschiedeten
sich unter tränen nach kanada mit dabei
die zweieinhalbjährige tochter an ihrer
nach einer beschwerlichen reise
erreichten sie endlich ihr ziel ein paar
abgelegene holzhütten
[Musik]
das schild mit dem schweizer kreuz steht
für einen traum den traum eines kleinen
gästehauses den peter kruse und monika
lehnert gemeinsam leben wollen und
vielleicht hat sie dieser traum
unvorsichtig werden lassen als sie vor
acht monaten per handschlag das gasthaus
übernahmen nun droht maxi vorgänger und
geschäftspartner den deal platzen zu
lassen
und ihn ab
sofort einfach vor dem vertrauen das
unser quartier
biologisch und
nur noch wenige stunden bis zum
entscheidenden gespräch das ohne kameras
statt finden wird max will nicht dass
das fernsehen weitere bilder von ihm
dreht
der eigentümer vom gasthaus ist übrigens
nicht max sondern der lokale polizeichef
aber ihn haben die beiden auswanderer
noch nie getroffen
das meer liegt nur gerade 300 meter vom
gasthaus entfernt monika und peter
hoffen dass es nicht ihr letztes bad in
kambodscha sein wird
[Musik]
es ist ein abschiedsfest das 19
schlittenhunde keinen schlaf finden
lässt der letzte abend in der schweiz
für daniel schaffer und carolin
schneider
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nach einem langen fest sind die
auswanderer nicht eben ausgeruht dabei
steht eine viertägige reise nach
schweden an
rolf kaiser ist ein guter freund von
daniel auch er wandert mit familie nach
schweden aus
als letztes werden die schlittenhunde in
die anhänger verfrachtet die abreise
steht unmittelbar bevor
[Musik]
müsste da sich die reise über knapp 3000
kilometer zieht fährt rolf ohne seine
familie
sie wird später nachkommen
daniel verabschiedet sich von seiner
mutter
[Musik]
herzlich zurückzulassen
und er ist gut so passt
[Musik]
gefordert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als ehemaliger polizist hält sich daniel
schafer selbstverständlich ans
tempolimit doch vielleicht hilft eine
prominent platzierte leuchtweste
schneller durch den zug zu kommen
hallo sagen wohin geht's noch schweden
norwegen aus die möbel sind schon
unterwegs jetzt kommen wir noch am
anfang waren ja sicher 800 dabei hier
hinten drin
ja
danke schön
für den kölner ist es nur ein auto mehr
dass die grenze passiert doch führt
daniel und caroline ist es der schritt
in ein ganz neues leben
[Musik]
in kanada soll es über zwei millionen
sehen geben heißt es einer davon ist der
blick
ein abgeschiedenen ort einer tagesreise
von der nächsten stadt entfernt
hier richtet die familie blum gerade ihr
neues leben ein sie wohnen in einem
einfachen camp das dem kanadier eric
solle manson und seine tochter keiner
gehört rick bietet den schweizern kost
und logis und sie helfen ihm dafür beim
betrieb der lodge
kennengelernt haben sich die blumes und
trick während ihrer kanada ferien sechs
wochen verbrachte die familie letztes
jahr am blackjack
tochter amira war damals gerade mal 18
monate alt aber sie kennt das gelände
doch bestens
20 quadratmeter wohnfläche ein plumpsklo
draußen holzheizung die familie blum hat
ein leben ohne luxus gewählt
[Musik]
der temperatur ist eigentlich
für diese gespielt sind wohlhabend zelt
übernachtet also dienen
also
[Musik]
was bist ohne stern mit christine
strom gibt es nur selten von einem
generator das wasser muss im see geholt
werden
[Musik]
mainz erkennt verletzter und und
wenn du darauf freut sondern ist ja
wieder mal leistungen so
somit weniger sie fast
immer
bei
amira ist das einzige kind hier weit und
breit freunde in ihrem alter wird sie am
black lake keine finden doch sie kann
sich der ständigen hingabe ihrer eltern
und der anderen erwachsenen sicher sein
und sie lebt auf dem größten
abenteuerspielplatz denn sich ein
zweieinhalbjähriges mädchen wünschen
kann
[Musik]
in circuit leben geschätzte 350.000
menschen nun wollen sich ganz am rande
der stadt zwei neue einwohner
niederlassen das wiesbaden guesthouse
soll lässt werden vor ein paar stunden
zweifelten sie noch daran denn der
bisherige pächter drohte die übergabe
scheitern zu lassen monika lehnert und
peter kruse gingen mit großen
befürchtungen zur aussprache mit ihrem
deutschen vorgänger max
wird
ich bin glücklich jetzt
monika und peter blieben im gespräch mit
ihrem geschäftspartner max standhaft und
pochten auf die abmachungen
nun ist es ihr guesthouse das
kambodschanisch schweizerische abenteuer
kann beginnen
ja wohl
[Musik]
alles machen
die ford eigentlich wenn es auch und bis
ganz
anders herum
bei ihrem letzten besuch als monika und
peter innerhalb von nur vier tagen
entschieden das gästehaus zu übernehmen
haben sich die beiden gar nicht alle
sechs zimmer angeschaut was sie nun
entdecken ist nicht nur erfreulich
max hat in seiner zeit als pächter dem
gasthaus wenig sorge getragen
[Musik]
und die kann man eventuell
für die anderen zimmer brauchen
gestrichen sodass ist
letzter
august zum renovieren
das war sehr spannend renovieren das ist
ja mal wieder ändert und das möbelhaus
tagen klar dass es keine pläne
das funktioniere hoch sind
naja aber bevor man sieht jetzt anders
machen nach
europa für maler frisch maler und europa
mussten die arbeiten mit dem pinsel
trippelt das ist logisch
[Musik]
sechs uhr morgens im hafen von rostock
von hier fährt die fähre nach schweden
um sie zu erreichen sind die auswanderer
die ganze nacht durchgefahren
unterbrochen nur von zwei stopps für die
hunde jetzt können sich die tiere
nochmals kurz austreiben
[Applaus]
mit auswanderer rolf gnadl seine
vierbeiner sie haben es verdient
dann müssen die schlittenhunde bereits
wieder zurück auf den anhängern für die
nächsten sechs stunden
daniel schaffer und carolin schneider
sind übernächtigt dabei haben sie erst
ein drittel der gesamten strecke bis
nach lappland zurückgelegt
[Musik]
seine klienten ist froh wenn mit alexa
britische stellt die prothese schmid ist
sie aber ziemlich
cool
die hunde müssen während der ganzen
überfahrt in den boxen bleiben es sind
so viele als dass sie raus dürften
[Musik]
am black lake in der kanadischen wildnis
bringt papa blum seiner tochter amira
das fischen bei diesmal darf sie es mit
einem echten angelhaken versuchen
frischer fisch ist ein wichtiger
bestandteil der speisekarte hier oben wo
der nächste supermarkt 12 autostunden
entfernt liegt
[Musik]
auch das erste kleine bauprojekt das die
blumes initiieren dient der gesunden
ernährung
das wird dieser
[Musik]
teil 1
amira ist immer mit dabei bei allem was
ihre eltern tun
sabrina und markus sind auch nach kanada
ausgewandert um mehr zeit für ihre
kleine tochter zu haben
dafür wird amira ohne gleichaltrigen
spielkameraden aufwachsen wenn sie ins
kindergartenalter kommt werden die
blumes neu entscheiden ob sie weiterhin
in dieser abgeschiedenheit leben wollen
[Musik]
nach vollbrachtem tageswerk hohen sich
markus und regt vor dem küchenhaus aus
die hütte ist der treffpunkt der kleinen
siedlung heute bereitet sabrina das
abendessen zu aber auch hier man kocht
häufig
ist
es ist schon spät obwohl es draußen noch
ziemlich hell ist
[Musik]
vater markus blum versucht sich noch
einmal in fischbach während sabrina die
tochter ins bett bringt
[Musik]
die abende sind ruhig haben
die blums leben hier in ihrer eigenen
kleinen welt
[Musik]
in kambodscha macht sich monika lehnert
daran er guesthouse einzurichten bis zur
geplanten eröffnung bleibt nur ein monat
zeit die vielen mängel die sie bei der
zimmer besichtigung festgestellt haben
bereiten der 43 jährigen ehemaligen
modeberaterin sorgen
und
hannes trinkl
[Musik]
diesen tagen bin ich sehr sehr nett
jetzt kann ich kenne nicht mal was
anbieten
richtig hunger schweinebraten mit
einem helm für sich aber keinen tresor
der biergarten wird mit namen roman los
die umleitung der schweizerischen post
funktioniert anscheinend bis nach
kambodscha
sie nimmt die erste bauliche maßnahme in
angriff der boden im hof soll mit
platten verschönert werden das erbe von
vorgänger max gefällt in beiden
auswanderer nicht
monika und peter rechnen mit kosten von
1000 dollar sie haben kaum finanziellen
spielraum und müssen das vernachlässigte
guesthouse mit möglichst wenig mitteln
auf vordermann bringen
[Musik]
wenn ich vorher schmal
überraschend taucht der besitzer vom
gästehaus auf herr wand er wohnt gleich
nebenan und sieht seine schweizer
nachbarn zum ersten mal
wir möchten den boden neu machen ist das
möglich
der besitzer versteht offensichtlich
kein englisch die hausangestellte
schänder hilft übersetzen
alles kein problem
der besitzer
ich habe ein geschenk für sie warten sie
herr wand da ist polizeichef der provinz
im rang eines generals der einstige
zugbegleiter peter kruse überreicht ihm
ein paar mitbringsel der bahnpolizei die
geschenke sollen den nachbarn gut
stimmen doch bald wird sich zeigen auch
der polizeichef hat nicht überall das
sagen
schweden empfängt seine neuen bewohner
mit dichten nebel
[Musik]
die auswanderer haben nur wenig
geschlafen carolin schneider ist nervös
caroline ist aufgeregt weil sie das auto
mit dem anhänger von der fähre
runterfahren soll
der ehemalige polizist daniel schafer
hat einen plan wenn am zoll die hübsche
caroline am steuer sitzt werden sie eher
durchgewinkt
geschwungen großen anhang und gewartet
[Musik]
die erste hürde ist geschafft sie sind
heil von der fähre runter und auf
schwedischem boden angekommen
[Gelächter]
doch noch steht der zeuge vor
niemand interessiert sich für die
auswanderer und ihrer hunde
daniel ist froh dass sie am zoll nicht
aufgehalten wurden
selbstverständlich haben sie alle
nötigen einreisepapiere aber jede
verzögerung wäre mühsam gewesen denn die
hunde müssen wieder mal raus aus ihren
boxen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
noch sind die hunde zwei tage und zwei
nächte von ihrem neuen zuhause entfernt
der campinganlage sancho garten in
lappland
[Musik]
am black lake gehen vater und tochter
blum derweil ihrem liebsten zeit
vertreiben
endlich hat es geklappt der erste fisch
ist gefangen
[Musik]
markus hat schon so manchen fisch
filetiert denn fische waren das
wichtigste nahrungsmittel der familie
blum als sie vor einem jahr zwei monate
lang durch die kanadische natur reisten
bei ihrem abenteuer in der wildnis war
die familie blum mit vier pferden
unterwegs nun bereitet sich markus
darauf vor seine weggefährten von einst
wieder zu treffen
markus und sabrina fahren zur alten
flugpiste wo sie die pferde vermuten sie
wollen sie einfangen und in scannt
bringen
die pferde gehören ihrem freund rick
simonson während des frühlings laufen
sie hier frei herum da
[Musik]
täuscht sich sabrina denn die beiden
anderen pferde denken gar nicht daran
ihre freiheit einfach so aufzugeben
[Musik]
dann ist es geschafft die beiden
sträucher sind eingefangen markus bringt
die vier pferde zurück ins lager an den
blick
das jetzt mit dem mit schafen und mit
der hauptrunde und kreiert und koppelt
und alle sind
aber auch die leben
danach richtig so gut
damit liegt man leute kennenlernen und
wichtig
[Musik]
kambodscha hat viele bezaubern des
sehenswürdigkeiten aber das land ist
nicht eben reich an schönen stränden wer
ans meer will fährt nach juneau quälen
touristen wie auch die kambodschaner
selbst während man am strand die seele
baumeln lässt der 300 meter davon
entfernt gearbeitet
nur einen tag nachdem der neue boden in
auftrag gegeben wurde sind die arbeiter
bereits zur stelle
es geht zügig voran da wird monika lier
hat zu einem unerwarteten gast gerufen
es ist die frau des polizeichefs und
vermieters frau manta
[Musik]
monika ist allein im gasthaus und
offensichtlich nervös
die angestellte übersetzt dass frau
wanda gerne wissen möchte weshalb
bauarbeiter hier sind
wir machen die bodenplatten neue rund
ums haus und den ganzen hof
das passt der hausherr reden gar nicht
abbruch der übung die arbeiter können
ging
monika versucht herauszufinden was frau
wand dafür ein wunder schließlich hat
der mann ja grünes licht für den neuen
boden gegeben
und sie ja was für die gedeihen anzahl
und der mailbox
jeder und jetzt alles
sie meint jetzt
es wäre gut wenn man die gleiche würde
auch wie sie dahin will ich platt aber
da sind die werde gern neben
den polizisten gewandt also ich habe ihn
seit mein schatz dass gott alles über
den moment als
ihr habt für die ganz platz betrieben
und größe wie
eine zwickmühle entweder sie geben
doppelt so viel geld für den boden aus
wie geplant oder sie verärgern die
hausherrin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach fast 3000 kilometer autofahrt sind
daniel schafer und carolin schneider
kurz vor dem ziel
es war eine kräftezehrende reise mit
übernachtungen er irgendwo am
straßenrand
nun wollen die auswanderer nur noch
eines endlich ankommen in ihrem neuen
zuhause der campinganlage lange geraden
hofer
roxel
[Musik]
die hunde können es kaum erwarten aus
ihren boxen rauszukommen nach vier tagen
reise
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aufgrund einer verzögerung mit der
baubewilligung existiert noch keine
zwingeranlage für die hunde fürs erste
werden sie einfach an stangen im freien
festgebunden
die auswanderer haben kaum zeit sich
auszuruhen denn sie übernehmen die
campinganlage in laufendem betrieb sie
ist ab sofort geöffnet
[Musik]
die familie blum hat eine vision die
wohnung werde trackings für touristen
anbieten und so ihr geld verdienen nun
bereiten sie sich vor für einen ersten
kurzen ausritt
markus nimmt ein gewehr mit es ist zwar
nicht geladen doch das pferd soll sich
schon von anfang an daran gewöhnen
sabrina ist vom letzten jahr daran
gewöhnt mit amira auf dem rücken zu
reiten aber damals war der kleine noch
einiges leichter
[Musik]
nein
für ihre geplanten pferde trackings
dürfen die blues das ganze bad gebiet
ihres freundes und geschäftspartners
trick nutzen und das ist mit 5000
quadratkilometern annähernd so gross wie
der kanton bern
im gesamten gebiet verteilt sind neun
camps oder hütten in denen übernachtet
werden kann
[Musik]
in einem jahr möchten die bruins die
ersten touren anbieten bis dahin gibt es
viel zu tun rothen und wege vorbereiten
hütten instand stellen und sich wieder
an die pferde gewöhnen die sie nun ein
jahr nicht mehr geritten sind
reagiert
es ist sommer in kanada aber die
temperatur liegt bei nur 10 grad
in der hitze ist wales kommt roman zu
besuch der schweinebraten koch vom
biergarten und aushilfs postbote
die schweizer auswanderer haben schon
einen gast der bauunternehmer ist hier
wegen der kosten für den neuen boden
der bauunternehmer kalkuliert sehr
großzügig
diese offerte müssen sich die beiden
erst einmal durch den kopf gehen lassen
jeder
versuchen das beste aus den usa ganz
klar dass sie hart noch braungebrannt
neuankömmlinge
das paradies auf erden fällt auch in
kambodscha nicht von monika lehnert und
peter kruse steht noch viel arbeit bevor
[Musik]
am black lake erholen sich die pferde
von ausritt
[Musik]
die familie blum macht sich in ihrer
hütte gedanken über die zukunft werden
sie von ihren pferde trackings leben
können zwei jahre geben sie sich zeit
bis dahin sollten sie mit dem ersparten
durchkommen
oder was noch machen überhaupt das thema
und das
projekt also dass man mit mickey und und
schlechter
auf die flussläufe möchte die hütte von
mir löcher und risse mit ross lange
triebwagen so wendig sehr sehr abgelegen
nach dem motto
bist schön
der winter kommt tatsächlich schon bald
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
dann gibt es schöne neuigkeiten
die schwangerschaft hinter die familie
nicht daran an einen noch abgelegenere
ort zu fliegen als black lady
ebenfalls nachwuchs gibt es in schweden
beim einrichten tauchen die ersten
probleme auch
in kambodscha muss nicht nur der boden
erneuert werden
[Musik]
und überraschung beim eröffnungsfest
vorgänger max ist der erste gast
[Musik]
die muss ich die gerne mit alkohol
träumen
sie
rufen
[Musik]